the youngest candidate hard spoken for
campaign tray the clear front-runner so
start with the shoulder in a little my
name is Gary Hardin I'm running for
president I want you to think about the
opportunity that we have right here
right now I've never known a guy more
talented at untangling politics so that
anyone can understand it is a gift and
he wants to share that and the whole
anybody wants is for him to take the
stupid photo you will never understand
that Gary Hart is the man to beat in 88
if we hold ourselves to those highest
standards in the voters cannot do
otherwise
senator want to ask you some questions
about the woman in your townhouse can
you tell us how you know her
you can't be serious no one is thing in
my home there's no need for that
[Music]
some one thing I asked to say you don't
embarrass me you can't hide from this
the cameras go everywhere it's up to us
to hold these guys to count just because
some other paper use gossip post front
page news I mean that doesn't mean we
have this does it does now with power
and that takes certain responsibilities
we need to say something it's nobody's
business none of it is okay but we're
not talking about that you're talking
about how you get through today
this campaign is about the future not
rumors not sleaze and I care about the
sanctity of this process what do you do
or do not
go on Gary
see it there's gonna be a story tomorrow
about me
[Music]